. Is Donald Trump actually instituting the
martial law that we were warned Barack Obama
was actually going to institute if you were
paying attention to politics during the Barack
Obama administration?
You might remember the unhinged, belligerent
fear mongering from the right that Barack
Obama plans to enact martial law in the United
States.
Some versions of the conspiracy said that
it was part of a plan to enslave people in
FEMA camps.
Sometimes RFID chips were involved, sometimes
not up.
And all of this was part of Obama's bigger
plan to suspend the 2012 election, which he
didn't do.
And then it was actually about suspending
the 2016 election and remaining in power indefinitely
while bringing authoritarian, militaristic
terror to the streets of America against the
wishes of state and local authorities and
elected officials.
And if you were paying attention, you knew
that Barack Obama had no interest in doing
any such thing.
There was no chance whatsoever that that was
what Barack Obama was going to do.
But that gets us to today.
And we actually have to have a discussion
today about whether Donald Trump is indeed
instituting martial law by the forceful deployment
of paramilitaries to cities around the country,
where if you look at Portland, for example,
those troops have teargassed the mayor of
Portland.
More on that later attacked reporters and
journalists.
And so the first step is, what is martial
law?
If we don't know what it is, it's hard to
determine whether we are seeing it.
While martial law is when normal civil functions
and civil law are replaced by military control.
Sometimes martial law can be declared during
a real or fabricated emergency situation as
a lead up to or after a coup in the context
of a natural disaster or states of emergency.
And there's some other situations as well.
And often martial law includes any or all
of the following.
The military in the streets working as local
law enforcement, curfews, the suspension of
habeas corpus and normal due process, military
law and justice being applied to civilians.
So do we have literal martial law today in
the United States?
No, we don't.
Up is what Donald Trump has done so far.
Literal fascism.
It's not.
But we are seeing what the early phases of
potentially future widespread martial law
could look like if slowly deployed.
Now, if you deny this basic fact, you're denying
reality right now.
It's not all happening at once.
It's not completely obvious unless you look
step by step.
But that's what makes it harder to see.
And in fact, authoritarian dictators understand
this.
And they often deploy martial law in baby
steps.
Now, again, to be completely clear, I am not
saying we will soon have a fully authoritarian
police state martial law situation in the
United States.
And part of the reason we may not is Trump
will run out of time.
He will either win reelection and no longer
need these authoritarian escalations to try
to help himself get reelected or he will lose.
And as far as I'm concerned, he will leave
office and thus it will stop the escalation
as well.
But think through the steps.
Donald Trump is deploying federal troops,
armed power paramilitaries to cities and towns.
These troops aren't part of the normal military
branches.
They're part of homeland security.
But they really are a military that is functioning
at the pleasure of the president as local
law enforcement, overriding local law enforcement,
camouflaged with body armor, carrying heavy
weapons, throwing people into unmarked vans.
Even local politicians and reporters are getting
hit now.
Many of them are being released after being
thrown into a van and brought to who knows
where.
And it's true that when you look at some of
the worst police states and martial law situations
of the last 40, 50 years around the world,
many of them don't release people without
charges if it turns out they don't want to
charge you.
Sometimes they bring you into a dark room
and they kill you and you never hear from
them again.
You never hear fee.
You are never heard from again.
And this happened to friends of my parents
in the 1970s during the military dictatorship
in Argentina.
It's not where we are and we're not actually
close to that right now, but at least colloquially,
they are replacing civil law with troops,
federal troops, quite literally, if mayors
and governors don't want them there.
They are in conflict with local law enforcement.
They are enforcing a sort of federal military
law and putting it above supreme to local
law enforcement.
Now, the typical justification is being given.
This also fits with history, which is that
it's an emergency.
Now, this gets a sense it interesting territory.
The incredible thing is that we have real
emergencies right now.
We have an emergency, which is the pandemic
and the mishandling of the pandemic by the
federal government, meaning the Trump administration.
We have another emergency, which is the economic
crisis happening, which is far worse than
it had to be as a result of Donald Trump's
mishandling of the pandemic.
But that's not the emergency that Donald Trump
is actually pointing to to justify these troops
in Portland and Chicago and other places soon.
Trump is saying the emergency is out of control.
Cancel culture, protesters destroying statues
and federal property and trying to burn courthouses
to the ground.
That's not the real emergency.
In fact, that's not even actually happening
as described.
The emergency is a thousand or more people
per day.
Again, dying of corona virus, 11 percent unemployment.
The pending eviction crisis, cuts to the unemployment
insurance benefits and the like.
That's the emergency.
But that's not why Trump says he's sending
in the troops.
So now they start bolstering this environment
of fear and panic as a result of the federal
troops being there.
And people are starting to wonder, how long
are we going to live like this?
Are we going to be able to vote normally in
November?
Are these troops going to be intimidating
me at the voting booth in November by patrolling
with heavy weapons?
And this is quite literally the way it's done.
This is out of the playbook playbook, slowly
creeping in to where we start thinking, well,
it's normal to have the armed pallette paramilitaries
in cities across the country.
But this next thing isn't yet normal.
But then you get the next thing.
OK, now that's normal.
But the next thing isn't yet normal.
It's the slow normalization.
Now, there they have the benefit that there
are some people already on the side of the
paramilitaries.
That's another issue.
And we'll talk about that probably not today,
but maybe later in the week.
So if you're waiting for one day at which
we confirm today at 12, 15 p.m., we have now
reached martial law or something like that
by design.
That's not how it happens.
It started with years ago.
Trump joking about maybe I'll stay in power.
I like the idea of how China now allows the
president to be reelected indefinitely.
Trump attacking the free press, kicking out,
you know, early on, I think it was Jim Acosta
from the White House briefings momentarily.
And, you know, it starts with that attacks
on the press, et cetera, that became normalized.
Trump attacks the press all the time, now
barely gets attention.
Well, then now there's troops in Portland
and soon in Chicago and other cities next.
And some people are already fine with it because
they believe Donald Trump's explanation for
why we need the troops to be there in the
first place.
And then before you know it, we have a national
emergency with paramilitaries deployed nationwide
regularly repressing not just peaceful protesters
with flowers and signs, but even attacking
journalists and members of the press covering
what's going on, which we are already seeing,
and potentially increase.
And then you've got Trump's federal troops
on Election Day presiding over an election
in which Trump himself is trying to get himself
reelected.
If you thought Secretary of State Brian Kemp
in Florida running the election in which he
was a candidate for governor was bad, then
think about Trump deploying paramilitaries
to supervise his own reelection campaign.
This is how it creeps in.
And I hope people are starting to see it and
realizing how important it is to put a stop
to this.
And, you know, put a stop to it.
We may not be able to stop the deployment
of the troops, but by not taking our eye off
the ball, which is this is a desperate, cornered
president who sees the polls and knows as
of today that he's losing and he could be
embarrassed in a historic Electoral College
rout by Joe Biden.
If things don't change, right, that's the
whole point.
He is now extremely desperate and that's very
dangerous.
And so we need to make sure that at the top
level, this is not allowed to change the character
of the November election in five weeks.
There are certain states that can start early
voting absentee.
Do it every single week.
Do not be dissuaded.
Keep your eye on the ball, because we've only
got three months to go.
We know the plan.
We know the slow creeping of authoritarianism.
We're seeing it right now.
We've been hearing about it from people like
Timothy Snyder and others for a long time.
This is this is it.
This is no longer a rehearsal.
We've got three months.
And this is the game plan.
And we're starting to see the signs.
We're going to continue covering this on the
David Pakman show, Instagram page, which I
invite you to follow at David Pakman show.
While you're there, follow me on Instagram
at.
David got Pacman for a break from the authoritarianism,
non politics, nonpolitical stuff on my Instagram
page.
We'll take a quick break.
I do want to talk about the latest Senate
predictions, and so much happened over the
weekend to catch you up on The David Pakman
Show David Pakman dot.com.